[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'economia che si studia nei primi corsi
di università presenta un idea dell'uomo
come di una creatura fondamentalmente
egoista le risorse a nostra disposizione
sono poche e limitate e l'idea è che
ogni individuo abbia in base al proprio
interesse la propria indole alle proprie
conoscenze ma soprattutto le proprie
necessità e propri desideri nelle
preferenze degli ordini di idee su come
allocare queste risorse tra sé e gli
altri e soprattutto sul valore dell'area
queste risorse che punto dipende dagli
interessi e desideri di ciascuno
e allora l'idea è che poi ognuno un po
per sea si procacci queste risorse tutti
contro tutti
e questa divisione e può creare però dei
risultati quasi casuale in cui non è
detto che a ciascun individuo siamo
toccati i beni che più potrebbero
soddisfarlo fargli raggiungere il
maggior livello di felicità e allo
stesso tempo non è detto che ogni bene
sia capitato nelle mani della persona
che potrebbe star ne maggior valore e
ink un valore che va a tutta la società
perché quando questo valore che è
nascosto nelle cose e che esiste solo in
relazione a ciò che noi desideriamo che
con le cose vogliamo fare non viene
scoperto a soffrirci alla società in
generale
ma questa non è per forza un idea
negativo negativa della nostra cultura
della nostra società e della nostra
specie
infatti se benessere del singolo dipende
dal livello di felicità raggiunta dal
benessere raggiunto e insieme benessere
del gruppo dipende dalla somma di tutte
queste piccole felicità individuale che
sono felicità sempre che vanno comparate
con un limite che è quello del numero
delle nostre risorse della quantità
delle nostre risorse
allora può ben essere che un sistema
come questo che permetta ai singoli di
inseguire queste piccole felicità
individuali e poi soprattutto permette
ai singoli di scambiarsi le risorse di
commerciale proprio in base a quel
valore che relativo a quello che noi con
le risorse vogliamo fare ai loro
desideri
allora può essere che questo sia il
sistema più efficiente nel senso che poi
il sistema che produce più valore
un valore che va alla società anche se
ognuno agisce solo per se stessa e
quindi questi egoismi individuali e
insieme possono anche creare il
benessere del gruppo eppure il termine
egoismo è ancora carico di un accezione
negativa che è difficile da lasciarsi
alle spalle a nessuno di noi piace
sentirsi dare dell'egoista ma
soprattutto a quanti noi capiterà di
dirsi da soli in continuazione
ora mi merito di pensare a me stesso
adesso è il momento di essere la mia
prima priorità ora mi posso concedere
oppure mi devo concedere di essere
egoista quasi che un pensiero prevista
sia un peccato così grave
qualcosa che nel profondo sappiamo
essere talmente sbagliato che ogni volta
che ce lo concediamo dovessimo pagare un
prezzo un prezzo che calcoliamo in
interessi in attenzione data da altri
implicazioni impostano le stesse quasi
che ogni volta che ci diciamo queste
frasi che ci meritiamo di essere egoisti
volessimo dire che alla fine all'egoismo
e un po la nostra pulsione è necessaria
qualcosa che ci viene naturale ma che ci
possiamo permettere solo se lo
bilanciamo con ciò che invece ci viene
innaturale allora sembra che vogliamo
dire che ci venga e naturale e leader e
noi stesse pensare agli altri che non è
un approccio molto sincero all'altro e
xix secolo addirittura stata coniata una
parola nuova di zecca altruismo
proprio per rispondere a chi sosteneva
che invece nell'egoismo non ci fosse
nulla di male in sé anzi è anche per
separare proprio i due piani per dire
che tra l'essere egoista e l'essere
altruista ci fosse una barriera
invalicabile fossero due piani talmente
diverse che qualsiasi istinto qualsiasi
azione qualsiasi pensiero potesse
rispondere solo a uno di questi due
istinti mai a entrambi
ma è così vero che chi pensa a se stesso
anche se magari non vuole il male degli
altri
però sicuramente non pensa al loro bene
ed è così vero che soprattutto quando a
parlare di temi importanti come
l'ecosistema il cambiamento climatico
allora l'unico modo di fare del bene è
primario nelle stesse di qualcosa
limitarci è così vero che ogni nostro
più innato quasi involontario desiderio
alla fine è contrario al benessere della
comunità tanto che dobbiamo sempre a
limitarci pensando a qualcun altro
qualcosa di esterno che siano
l'ecosistema le piante la flora marina o
le generazioni future che poi ormai lo
sappiamo in questi mesi se ne è parlato
tanto che se questa è la logica allora
quando andiamo ad avere qualche idea
applicazione sia come singolo sia
soprattutto come comunità come società
che va contro il benessere del pianeta
va a mettere in pericolo
e ad aggravare il fenomeno dei
cambiamenti climatici allora questi
altri in nome dei quali paradossalmente
dovremo limitare noi stessi non dovremmo
neanche andare a cercare così lontano
perché siamo noi stessi e da 30 anni
quelli che ne pagheranno le conseguenze
e insomma è così vero che tutto ciò che
noi vogliamo veramente ciò che
sicuramente desidereremmo se tutte le
nostre azioni non avessero tutti questi
vincoli in queste conseguenze è qualcosa
di negativo per gli altri io non penso
che sia così vero perché penso che
dipenda effettivamente dal ciò che noi
vogliamo poi non è che solo i singoli
come individui o come gruppi abbiano
degli interessi delle volontà le società
le aziende gli stati hanno tutti la loro
volontà dei loro interesse e questa idea
di un uomo economico ed egoista si
applica soprattutto a loro
e questo schema è alla base di molti
degli interventi regolatori e delle
leggi di vari stati poi proprio sugli
stati o un esempio perfetto quasi un
caso studio di come interessi come gli
egoismi individuali possono essere
sfruttati in realtà per portare al bene
comune
sto parlando del protocollo di kyoto del
1997 in dei profili in cui è stato poi
ripreso e aggiornato anche dall'accordo
di parigi sul clima
il protocollo di kyoto come forse un po
lo conosciamo tutti è un trattato
internazionale in cui gli stati
partecipanti riconoscendo il consenso
scientifico sull'esistenza del fenomeno
dei cambiamenti climatici e sull'alta
possibilità che sia causato dall'uomo
impegnati entro il 2020 a ridurre il
livello di emissioni di co2 del 18 per
cento
in teoria e semplificando ogni stato
dovrebbe ridurre le proprie emissioni di
una quota del 18 per cento ma in pratica
non tutti gli stati non hanno le
capacità per riuscirci questo perché ci
sono stati da una parte che non hanno le
capacità finanziarie
magari oppure non hanno le capacità
tecnologiche per fare questi interventi
oppure ci sono ancora stati che non
hanno interessi politici ed economici
per partecipare a questa corsa alla
riduzione delle emissioni per l'altra
parte invece ne sono stati le cui linee
politiche mettono questo tipo di
interventi al primo posto ma attenzione
queste sono stati che avrebbero ben
piacere anche di ricavare profitti da
questi investimenti oltre che
incidentalmente salvare il pianeta
quindi da una parte abbiamo questi stati
che non solo potrebbero raggiungere
hanno la potenzialità per raggiungere il
loro 18 per cento di quota ma avrebbero
anche probabilmente la potenzialità per
ridurre le emissioni e per tutti
raggiunge da soli l'obiettivo globale
dall'altra stati che per tutta una serie
di mancanze o anche molto semplicemente
perché a loro costa di più magari
ridurre rispetto agli altri non possono
partecipare
stando così le cose avremo gli stati a
riducono senza altri incentivi fino alla
loro quota del 18 per cento ma non vanno
oltre gli stati b che non partecipano
l'obiettivo globale del protocollo di
kyoto non potrebbe mai essere lì
aggiunto ed è qui allora che il
protocollo a un meccanismo per sfruttare
queste che sono alla fine egoismi degli
stati
il protocollo di kyoto crea una specie
di mercato per l'inquinamento vale a
dire per quel surplus di riduzione che
gli stati a potrebbero ridurre ma non
producono questi stati possono vendere
sei estati vi conviene vuol dire se gli
stati a costa meno ridurre rispetto a
quanto costerebbe agli stati b possono
vendere quel surplus agli stati b che
ora se lo possono permettere
in questo modo abbiamo gli stati a che
effettivamente fanno da soli il lavoro
riducono del 18 per cento per tutti
raggiungono da soli
l'obiettivo globale
ma non lo fanno per un interesse
altruistico o per una volontà di
combattere i cambiamenti climatici a
tutti i costi e proprio parliamo di
costi economici lo fanno perché possono
ricavare profitti perché ora gli stati b
possono permettersi di acquistare quel
surplus e c'è uno scambio potrebbe
sembrare un sistema poco sincero eppure
non è un mondo perfetto ma è un mondo
che in questo schema in questa carta
funzione permetterà di raggiungere un
obiettivo che altrimenti non potrebbe
essere raggiunto in definitiva sfrutta
gli egoismi individuali degli stati il
subordinare non solo una lotta comune
del nostro specie della nostra comunità
ma anche se vogliamo un obbligo che si
sono assunti sul piano del diritto
internazionale
una specie di tornaconto personale
sfrutta questi egoismi per raggiungere
il benessere comune
ma per rispondere meglio alle domande di
prima io credo che si possa andare
ancora oltre
per avvicinare egoismo ed altruismo se è
vero che sono cose così diversa in
psicologia sociale si utilizza una scala
particolare la social valley orientation
che indica le preferenze di un individuo
nella locale risorse tra sé e gli altri
vale a dire più alto è il valore di
social by orientation di un individuo
più quella persona considera il
benessere degli altri e della comunità
un fattore fondamentale nel prendere le
proprie scelte considerare gli altri la
comunità anche condividiamo come un
elemento principale in quello che
vogliamo fare non è qualcosa di innato
forse è qualcosa che apprendiamo nella
nostra comunità e la cultura cui
cresciamo qualcosa che apprendiamo sede
nemo autorizzata il rispetto della
cultura il rispetto della cittadinanza
dell'ambiente degli altri è qualcosa che
invece dimentichiamo in società e
culture che valorizzano l'omertà
l'ignoranza i meriti dei furbi sono
quello degli onesti
eppure studi dimostrano che il 46 per
cento degli individui presenta valori di
social vale orientation altissime vale a
dire il 46 per cento degli individui
considera il benessere degli altri
comuni
ora è fondamentale nelle proprie scelte
allora e ancora vera questa concezione
dell'uomo come di una creatura
fondamentalmente egoista io penso che si
possa è stata in quella vera ma non solo
vera possa essere sostenibile perché
appunto dipende da ciò che noi vogliamo
e il fatto che il 46 per cento degli
individui voglia il bene della comunità
oltre al proprio può essere un buon
segno in una società che ci educa e ci
valorizza in questo senso pensare agli
altri pensare alle comunità che
condividiamo a partire dall'ambiente può
diventare l'oggetto del nostro egoismo
d'altruismo può essere l'oggetto del
nostro egoismo allora a quel punto se
pensare agli altri e ciò che noi
vogliamo rispondere a noi stessi non è
qualcosa per cui dobbiamo sentirci in
errore ma è semplicemente fare quello
che dobbiamo fare
dare retta quello che noi vogliamo e
incidentalmente fai il bene comune
proseguendo il proprio in questa lotta
in questa ricerca della propria felicità
ma tutti trovandola anche nel benessere
comune siamo tutti in prima linea
e allora non dobbiamo meritarci di
essere egoisti dobbiamo essere egoisti
tutti i giorni grazie
[Applauso]